[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour un autre espace autochtones en
direct je m'appelle anne-marie yvon
aujourd'hui nous allons parler des
élections qui auront lieu la semaine
prochaine le 30 janvier
c'est l'assemblée des premières nations
du québec et du labrador qui va se
choisir un nouveau chef
alors vous avez été invités à poser des
questions aux deux candidats donc nous
allons leur parler aujourd'hui nous
allons poser les questions qui vont
entrer au fur et à mesure on en a déjà
quelques-unes on attend les autres tout
ce que je vous explique c'est que cette
assemblée allait composer des 43 chefs
des dix communautés en fait des
communautés donc représentée par dix
nations il n'y a en fait que les inuit
qui ne font pas partie de cette
assemblée et ses dix nations se
retrouvent sur le territoire du québec
mais également du labrador
alors ceux qui vont voter ce sont ces 43
chefs ils vont voter donc pour le chef
régional
le chef régional qui va les représenter
à l'assemblée des premières nations du
canada qui est dirigée actuellement par
le chef perry bellegarde
les deux candidats intéressés à a dirigé
la pnq elles sont je vous les présente
l'actuel chef ghislain picard ghislain
picard bonjour jours alors vous êtes en
studio avec moi et nous avons à
chicoutimi pour représenter radio canada
saguenay monsieur gilbert dominique à
vous êtes là bonjour aux échos et à tous
les deux merci de nous retrouver chef
dominique enfin que je dis chef parce
que vous êtes l'ancien chef de
mashteuiatsh mais on vous allez nous le
nous l'expliqué dans quelques instants
donc nous vous avons invité tous les
deux pour participer à ce débat d'idées
alors je le disais aux internautes si
vous avez envie de poser des questions
c'est le moment de le faire là aller sur
facebook allait poser des questions
elles vont arriver au fur et à mesure et
nous allons pouvoir les présenter aux
deux candidats
voici comment nous allons fonctionner
évidemment on va s'assurer que ce soit
une conversation équitable alors on va
vous donner un temps de parole à tous
les deux au fur et à mesure des
questions
il ya un chronomètre qui va apparaître
en bas de l'écran pour nous dont vous
allez voir le temps passer et vous allez
pouvoir répondre à l'intérieur de ce
laps de temps dont pour que ce soit
équitable pour tous on va commencer avec
une présentation de chacun de vous je
vais vous donner deux minutes trois
minutes allons-y avec trois minutes
puisqu'il est indiqué donc trois minutes
à chacun de vous pour vous présenter
donc qui vous est de vos grands atouts
vos qualités pour être un chef monsieur
dominique on va commencer avec vous
remercie donc j'ai été chef de ma
communauté pendant trois mandats donc au
total onze ans comme chef de la première
nation salle des pipots 2000 note g ou
par un fin de mandat comme conseiller
élu donc un total de six ans comme
conseiller donc j'ai quand même derrière
moi un bagage politique là d'autour de
17 ans lors d'un mon milieu je vous
dirais que ce plan professionnel à 10,9
un jeu devenait directeur des loisirs à
m'acheter iax laquelle fonctions que
j'ai occupées pendant une dizaine
d'années à 20 de cofonder ce qu'on peut
appeler les jeux autochtones interbank
avec des ennemis
donc j'ai été le directeur général
également de sceptre merveilleuse
organisation qui soit dit en passant
cette année ont lieu dans la communauté
de wash ac mak mani utenam c'est un
événement lors qu'ils accueillent année
en apprend des lots autour de 800 à 1000
jeunes qui font du sport
partage également lors dé leur culture
donc c'est un événement mon sens tout à
fait la remarque ans comme chef dans la
communauté le soviet je dois vous avouer
que je suis assurément très fier de
quelques réalisations
on s'est donnés à partir d'une démarche
de concertation populaire des outils qui
sont pertinents là à considérer
lorsqu'un conseil fait sa planification
stratégique je vous dirai donc c'est un
site une politique d'affirmation
culturel et il ya une démarche également
de concertation sur place à science huit
lots à une série de suicides qui ont
marqué leur notre première nation donc
on s'est regroupé j'ai presté l'eau avec
déjà du milieu une table de concertation
n'a écouté la population et on a donné
un rapport qui encore aujourd'hui l'eau
est fortement utilisés pour aiguiller
lors les différentes stratégies là à
implanter dans la communauté mais
également comme chef j'ai eu l'occasion
là avec les deux préfets de mrc
différents qui avec quino cohabitant sur
notre territoire
de réaliser du développement énergétique
en raison de 55 ans ok donc cette
entente tout à fait novateur a permis
l'aménagement de deux mini centrales au
fil de l'eau et régis sur nos
territoires traditionnels et en
partenariat avec et en partenariat avec
le milieu municipal
on va générer des sommes extraordinaires
là pour notre communauté
tout autour au cours des 25 prochaines
années on parle autour de 90 millions
donc je pense que je suis quelqu'un qui
est un projection qui est capable
d'avoir une vision puis de concrétiser
des partenariats
merci monsieur dominique maintenant je
déplie car c'est à votre tour donc qui
vous êtes vos grands atouts et vos
qualités pour devenir un chef
quid en outre mes deux chefs quoi tient
jusqu'à maintenant mais oui de mechiche
civile moins de 10 me a chip cinéma
dimona marc barani a d'abord à droite
guy legault d'oublier ce qui s'est dit
ou tu nous le saurons donc d'abord pour
vous remercier de nous donner cette
opportunité de présenter un peu notre
vision pour les trois prochaines années
et je voudrais tout de suite en partance
à lui mon frère c'est chef de
mashteuiatsh gilbert dominique et
très certainement salué sa décision de
convoiter ce poste-là au niveau régional
c'est une responsabilité extrêmement
extrêmement importante
je peux de toute évidence témoigne la
dette de tous les défis qui se
présentent à nous collectivement et je
pense avoir jeté commencer par la fin et
avoir un peu les qualités nécessaires
pour maintenir le cap
la direction concède années notamment
aux chats tête d'une plus grande
visibilité des questions qui nous
intéresse j'ai toujours insisté sur
l'importance de grande écoute
précédé par le respect de la grande
diversité qui nous unit au niveau au
niveau des premières nations et ça c'est
très certainement à mon sens avec les
années quelque chose que j'ai acquis et
toujours à l'écouté dans le respect des
diversités et ultime à la fin de la
journée savoir comment on fait converger
tous au vert une position que nous
sommes appelés à défendre je vais
reculer le pas en arrière parce que mon
passé inclus ces jo vraiment qui
composaient un peu mon éveil là comme
autochtones dans les années du collège
manitou à la maca zon entre 74 100 des
cent et c'est là que j'ai appris
finalement à étendre mes horizons comme
autochtone par rapport à la réalité
d'autres nations et ça m'a permis aussi
de mettre je dirais à profit un bagage
de connaissances pour passer à d'autres
états qui était celui d'un long séjour
en communication pour une communauté
ma participation aux radios
communautaires et par la suite de la
transition entre le monde des
communications et la politique s'est
fait presque je dirais automatiquement
naturellement parce qu'on peut pas
garder ce qui se passe autour de nous
sans seins et rapière réagir donc et je
pense que au chapitre des 25 dernières
années puis je vais faire d'ailleurs
à mon collègue gilbert on a eu une belle
opportunité en 2006 parce que ces
matches vierges qui en est l autre
d'avoir un forum socioéconomique qui a
mis en évidence ces réalités l'eau qui
sont de loin qui sont de loin à la
remorque qui sont très très à la
remorque de ce qu'on voyait au pays au
chapitre social ou chapelles économique
et je pense que c'est lors l'importance
de trouver les bonnes conditions pour
s'engager politiquement avec les
gouvernements mais aussi une des
priorités bien sûr comment on s'engage
entre nous comme comme nationale alors
maintenant en trois minutes
et là je vais commencer par chef picard
pourquoi est ce que vous voulez diriger
continuer en fait de diriger la pnq elle
la réponse la meilleure réponse se
retrouvent dans les avancées qu'on a
connu au cours des dernières années
selon moi plus récemment on a eu
l'arrivée d'un gouvernement du québec on
a une campagne électorale l'automne
dernier qui s'est conclue avec
l'élection d'un nouveau parti un nouveau
gouvernement une nouvelle vision
nouvelle l'idéologie sans doute et à
chaque fois qu'il ya eu un processus
électoral la question qu'on se pose est
est-ce qu'on est dedans ou pas v et pour
moi bon à travers les années j'ai
considéré que c'était beaucoup trop
important d'assurer notre participation
au processus électoral
malgré peut-être les limites au niveau
du de la participation de l'électorat
autochtone a dit bon je pense qu'on a
plus d'acquis aller chercher en
participant et en faisant valoir nos
droits
donc c'est vraiment le principe de
l'engagement avec les gouvernements qui
sont dans notre environnement politique
c'est
évidemment ce qu'on a cherché à assurer
avec le présent gouvernement de monsieur
legault avait quand même je dirais je
dis très très humblement avec quand même
des succès qu'ils sont très très notable
puisque la pnq elle a été dans la liste
des organisations que le premier
ministre ait permis d'appeler le
lendemain des élections on a réussi
garantie on en compte
en privé avec le premier ministre
quelques semaines après après l'élection
est d'ailleurs le premier ministre s'est
déplacé pour rencontrer les chefs dans
une rencontre prévue initialement pour
80 minutes qu'a duré trois heures mais
la partie est loin d'être gagnée
il ya encore beaucoup des fils de défi
qui se présente à nous mais je pense que
ultime à l'eau la première étape c'est
vraiment de s'assurer d'avoir les bonnes
conditions d'engagement parce que
autrement on est à la merci d'un
processus politique qu'on arrive
difficilement à contrôler je pense que
ce que nous défendons comme comme droits
fondamentaux comme premières nations au
niveau jeu c'est trop haut niveau les
droits ancestraux et issus de traités
ont beaucoup trop d'importance et pour
moi c'est vraiment le défi qui se
présente à nous et j'ai je suis confiant
que je suis capable de faire avancer ces
dossiers là il ya la partie fédérale
aussi qui est une autre réalité on it
on a une élection fédérale à l'horizon
pour quelques mois à peine
on semble avoir un peu le vent dans les
voiles avec le présent gouvernement mais
encore long il faut être vigilant
il faut être à l'écouté il faut être un
mode veille continuellement parce que
toute décision prise par le gouvernement
fédéral nom d'auteur sans penser qu'il
n'y a pas d'impact au niveau de nos
communautés
mais toute décision prise par des
gouvernements un impact et la question
le défi c'est que quelques secondes
souvent bon le gouvernement fédéral
parle beaucoup de partenariats et
souvent les définitions que nous on en a
et le gouvernement ne convergent pas ça
c'est un problème
et dernière chose c'est que tous on est
conditionné par notre propre relation
comme première
monsieur dominique à votre tour donc
pourquoi voulez vous dirigez la pnq elle
en trois minutes
oui enfin lorsque j'ai amorcé ma
réflexion là ce niveau là je me suis mis
personnellement à faire quelques
constats puis ces constats là je les ai
partagé avec quelques chefs et on se
rendait compte que malgré certaines
avancées inévitablement en 2019
maintenant
la peine qu elle dans sa structure
actuelle a atteint ses limites
à mon avis il ya un an nettement très
peu d'écouté de la part des
gouvernements au positionnement et aux
démarches effectuées par la pinte qu
elle donc la peine qu elle n'est pas
reconnu à sa juste valeur auprès des
différents gouvernements
il ya assurément là un manque au niveau
de la concertation c'est certainement
pas optimale on est supposé l'eau est
une organisation politique de 43
communauté et pour l'avoir vécu à
plusieurs reprises
il ya plusieurs joueurs qui sont absents
autour de la table
j'ai également j'ai fait le constat que
la peine qu elle entourée de l'ensemble
de ces commissions à qui nous confions
différents mandats et différentes
responsabilités est devenu graduellement
un organisation administratif et
voudrait que l'agenda de 2,2 et beaucoup
là en lien avec les obligations
administratives donc on est loin l'ont
nettement de faire de la politique ce
qui nous amène souvent loi être toujours
leur mode récupération ou en mode
réaction
et honnêtement dans plusieurs cas au
genou voilà je ne vois aller le 7 mai
que on est là quelque chose près d'un
groupe de pression donc moi je m'en fous
changer la donne il faut ramener bien
sûr là le politique claude le débat
politique autour avec les chefs autour
de cette table donc honnêtement je veux
aider concrètement les communautés l'eau
un regard des besoins
d'autodétermination et d'autonomie
gouvernementale
ok ya bien sûr cette structure là on
peut les soutenir dans leur cheminement
mais je veux que l'on actualise le
mandat de la peine qu elle et que l'on
confirme ses missions de permettre aux
chefs de faire de la réelle politique de
réfléchir à des stratégies
donc honnêtement je veux la contribué
pour que la peine qu elle soit reconnue
comme une organisation à caractère
politique
une organisation stratégique une hogra
une organisation innovante et bien
entendu performant une organisation qui
vont contribuer largement à établir
enfin une relation réelle de nation à
nation avec les différents gouvernements
pensent au québec
au fédéral et bien sûr avec les
premières dans les gouvernements des
premières nations donc c'est ce que je
souhaite leur proposer aux chefs alors a
en fait c'est intéressant parce qu'avant
de parler de vos priorités j'aimerais
bien qu'on débatte sur ce que vous venez
dire aussi parce que vous parlez des
limites atteintes par la pnq elle vous
dit que ça doit être actualisée
maintenant j'aimerais bien vous entendre
et agir l'un et l'autre par rapport à ça
monsieur picard chef picard à ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ça ce que vous
trouvez que la pnq elle a atteint ses
limites que l'aspect de politique et
évacué de l'assemblée becqueter
l'exercice de faire le bilan pour pour
toute organisation à mon sens va de soi
ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est que le
rôle du chef régional de l'apn qu'elle
n'est pas celui d'être un chef des chefs
et ça c'est important de le comprendre
parce que c'est une précision que moi
j'apporte régulièrement selon les
groupes que je rends compte à travers à
travers mon travail et ceci étant dit il
faut aussi savoir que you i quand même
une évolution de ce roulement aussi qui
fait en sorte que yo des responsabilités
qui se sont graduellement installée dans
le rôle et les responsabilités du sort
de l'actuel par exemple la question de
l'éducation populaire extrêmement
important à mon sens et c'est ce qui
nous a fait faire en sorte que
finalement on était en mesure de
rechercher des acquis écoutez en 2017
je veux dire on a vraiment garantit
notre place en marge des célébrations de
la ville de marjah 375 ans et je pense
qu'il ya quand même lors des
des résultats qui sont indéniables par
rapport au rayonnement de la question
autochtone ici même à montréal et ce
qu'on a comme défi c'est comment on
assure sur également l'eau ailleurs
aussi au chapitre de l'économie ben on a
fait des gains je pense dans la dernière
campagne électorale provinciale en
insistant sur le fait qu' arrêter de
vous limiter à l'immigration
si vous parlez de la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre il y aune nos populations aussi
qu'ils peuvent y contribuer
il s'agit de se doter d'un plan pour le
faire sur la réforme
j'ai insisté auprès des chefs dans le
plan que je leur propose que la première
étape après le processus électoral
c'est vraiment d'avoir un lac-à-l'épaule
une retraite fermée des chefs pour
justement définir un peu la ligne entre
la responsabilité que j'ai moi ou que le
chef régional doit voir et l'autonomie
des communautés et je pense que
l'intention l'objectif c'est de faire un
mariage qui vient finalement conforté
tout le monde est à mon sens j'ai
toujours insisté auprès des chefs que si
la paix actuelles et laisser un peu dans
un un mode d'improvisation ou ou la
peine qu elle est forcée de deviner un
peu la position le positionnement des
chefs
c'est clair qu'on est pas bien outil on
n'a pas les armes qu'il faut pour faire
avancer certaines positions et à mon
sens c'est vraiment aussi et je pense
que là tous les chefs sinon la majorité
des chefs vont être d'accord que cet
exercice là est nécessaire ça nous a été
dit en février
presque un an jour pour jour et c'est
pour cela que je sais sur le fait que la
première démarche de regarder un peu
comment cette relation là s'expriment
entre nous parce que je réitère je
réitère parce que la relation avec tous
les gouvernements fédéral provincial et
municipaux un départ et
écoutez en sorte de grand sommet des
maires et des chefs en août dernier on
répète l'expérience en 2019 donc c'est
important aussi d'aller créer 6 jan ces
alliances là avec les bonnes conditions
alors chef de mes chefs dominique pardon
monsieur dominique c'est à vous de
réagir et agir à ce que monsieur william
dit oui mais dans le fx match d'accord
avec chef picard avant sur la nécessité
lors de regrouper l'ensemble des des
chefs
moi je proposerai au chef également
d'éclater solo et d'inviter l'ensemble
des délits dans la politique de chacune
des communautés pour effectivement faire
le point fr les constants également il
ya eu des des tentatives là dans le
passé lors par exemple de créer des
forums l'heure relativement formelles
avec le gouverneur du québec
ok ça n'a pas donné les résultats
ce compte est donc faudrait apprendre
bien entendu tout ça parce que à mon
sens quand je parle d'une organisation
qui atteint ses limites c'est assurément
sur le plan politique à voir que
présentement dans notre intérêt
relations avec les gouvernements hockey
de haut niveau ici je parle des premiers
ministres ou des ministres qui prennent
des décisions le concert des premières
nations
outre le faire ou qui ont des rencontres
par exemple on a une assemblée générale
pendant une heure une heure et demie où
ils viennent faire des disco on n'a pas
l'occasion au rayonnement de débattre
donc moi ce que je pense qu'il faut
assurément permettre c'est que la peine
qu elle un bain bien entendu en
collaboration que les autres niveaux de
gouvernement puis cela ériger un forum
politique qui va voir mérite que les
acteurs d'un débat soit autour de cette
table et qu'un concrètement on aborde
les sujets qui sont importants et
fondamentalement important je dirais
pour l'avenir de notre première main
sont combien de fois quand on en a
transmis demandons sur la question du
territoire
du partage des ressources naturelles du
partage des redevances excellent et
particulièrement le québec ça toujours
été un dialogue de sourds jusqu'à
maintenant
donc moi je pense qu'il est apte à faire
c'est constant là et de voir bon
maintenant comment est ce que on se
rallie pour bien entendu la livrée des
réelle bataille politique
mais c'est sur la concertation la
mobilisation lors de l'ensemble des des
gouvernements des premières nations et
s'assurer que les 43 communauté tuer
cette solidaire également j'ai rencontré
les cris et je leur ai demandé là
les raisons qu'ils un air bien entendu à
ne pas être hautain présent qu'on
souhaiterait qu'elle attend du portel il
chemine dans leur propre
autodétermination et autres limites du
redémarrage pas ça pourrait être
intéressant pour les autres communautés
voir comment ils s'y prennent c'est quoi
leur stratégie et inversement
je pourrais leur dossier de l' expertise
d'autres communautés ont peu long à
partir de la peine qu elles mettent en
commun des enjeux et bâtir des
stratégies pour qu'à efficacement alors
on atteigne aussi lorsque la politique
oui monsieur dominique vous avez dit
vouloir faire la promotion de
l'autonomie gouvernementale des
communautés autochtones
alors avant de vous demander comment
vous comptez faire cela on a reçu une
question de nicole par facebook qui dit
quelle est la différence entre
l'autodétermination et l'autonomie
gouvernementale
alors monsieur denis je vais vous
laisser répondre monsieur picard vous
pouvez également vous intérêts dans la
conversation et vice versa les imf yeux
dominique webb a regardé un juge pas un
expert en matière juridique à clé mais à
mon sens ces deux notions qui sont
affirmant estimé lee est intimement lié
pardonnez moi alors je vais vous donner
bien sûr l'homme a défié ma définition
ma compréhension bien sûr la de cet
enjeu ou de ce droit qui à mon sens cela
elle fondamentalement important
également de chez les premières nations
parce que au moment du contact qui
encore aujourd'hui nous possédons bien
entendu là notre propre société nos
propres règles
ok on avait notre propre forme de
gouvernance hockey qui nous inspire bien
entendu encore aujourd'hui donc
l'autodétermination c'est bien entendu
l'en avoir le pouvoir pour un peuple de
se déterminer
elle n'est ni l'autonomie
gouvernementale
dans mon esprit c'est bien entendu la de
pouvoir l'a érigé une structure un
appareil gouvernemental qui vont être
capable par exemple de prendre en charge
ces papes responsabilité ou d'assumer
leur pleinement
la gestion de ses champs de compétence
ok donc c'est ma définition que je
voudrais que je pourrais vous partagez
d'accord monsieur picard chef picard
écoutez je pète prendre la balle au bond
parce que c'est en lien avec un
commentaire qui avait été fait plus tôt
par par gilbert parce que évidemment il
ya les commissions régionales qui
gravitent autour de la pnq elles qui
sont nés graduellement au cours des des
30 dernières années et qui accompagne
finalement les communautés qui viennent
renforcer un peu la capacité sur le plan
politique parce que dès qu'on parle
d'éducation de santé et de services
sociaux
il ya toujours l'élément politique et je
pense que ça c'est important
mais la responsabilité août en à peine
quelques des commissions qui en pensant
ne seront jamais des gouvernements
régionaux se ce n'est pas le mandat que
nous avons mais en même temps on se doit
aussi de se donner les capacités pour
renforcer la gouvernance
oui au niveau régional mais au niveau
local aussi et c'est là qu'entre en jeu
ce concept alors de thomas grenon mental
et le problème qu'on voit c'est que ya
encore aujourd'hui des paramètres sont
en tout respect aux communautés des
paramètres sont dictées par le
gouvernement fédéral principalement avec
une politique qui est désuète qui
remonte à 1995 et qui détermine les
paramètres de l'étendue de ce concept là
d'autonomie gouvernementale et ce que je
voulais ajouter à cela c'est que un
exemple puis je fais une parenthèse là
dessus c'est que il y aura par exemple
des responsabilités ou des compétences
que le gouvernement fédéral se garde qui
n'ont pas leur place dans la discussion
entre nos communautés le gouvernement
fédéral
c'est le cas par exemple tout tout ce
qui régit ce qu'on appelle comme étant
les affaires internationales
donc l'alena 2.0 je veux qu'ils aient
fait l'objet d'une entente entre canada
ne seraient exclus en théorie de notre
réponse est donc donc on fait des
percées parce que la line up 2.0 or
quand même une reconnaissance de notre
réalité et en même temps
l'autodétermination c'est vraiment le
langage international
on se rapproche jusqu'à la question du
débat ou du contexte légal
c'est possible consciente comme vous le
savez le projet de loi 2 62 de roméo
saganash est à l'étude par le sénat il y
aura peut-être des tactiques de ralentir
le processus parce que ce qui est
vraiment est mise en évidence
c'est toutes les questions qui sont
liées au territoire c'est toutes les
questions qui sont liées au droit de
veto ce que certains appellent le droit
de veto donc le consentement préalable
libre et éclairé et c'est là que le
gouvernent le sénat actuellement ralenti
sa démarche et ça semble comporter
certaines préoccupations 2 60-2 parle
vraiment de l'harmonisation des lois
canadiennes avec les principes de la
déclaration le droit à
l'autodétermination c'est vraiment la
liberté pour nous nos communautés de
choisir de pouvoir déterminer leur
développement social économique et
politique
alors voilà j'espère que ça répond à
votre question on y colle si vous avez
d'autres questions ne vous gênez pas
pour les poser tout de suite
j'en ai une là une autre question de
jacques crunch pour vous le connaissez
tous les deux chacun ne s'éteint un
intellectuel il vient d'ailleurs de
votre communauté monsieur dominique
c'est un ancien négociateur en chef pour
le conseil attikameks montagnais que
comptez-vous faire avec la loi sur les
indiens
monsieur dominique laroche aux indiens
honnêtement moi c'est une loin assuré m
désuète et il faut travailler fortement
pour qu'on évacue lors ce cette loi loi
cette loi là qui nous infantilise un an
nettement le moi c'est mon point de vue
bien personnelle et il faut par contre
renouveler sa part une formule de
reconnaissance la pleine et entière de
ce que nous sommes nous sommes un peuple
fier nous sommes les premières nations
et des peuples qui ont des droits
ancestraux sur l'ensemble des
territoires traditionnels y compris un
titre aborigène
donc faut remplacer ces formules là par
une formule là qui va être juste pour
une société de pouvoir s'épanouir ce
plan culturel se plaît économique ce
plan social sur également un territoire
qui lui est propre
ok donc moi je pense que la formule est
à ce niveau là et on voit ça et c'est là
avec cette loi-là d'être constamment
dépendant d'un autre état que que de
prendre en charge nos propres
responsabilités
moi honnêtement la ce qui m'anime en
politique c'est cette vision la dette un
jour là est en mesure de dire à mes
enfants que nous sommes un peuple
autonome c'est nous qui prenons nos
propres responsabilités
nous avons un territoire on prélève nos
ressources que nous avons bien bien
entendu a besoin pour notre
épanouissement
oui bien entendu on partage également
que nos voisins qui sont qui sont au
nord mais on est capable comme nono gras
par elles l'ont fait pendant des
milliers d'années lot de pouvoir
s'épanouir sur cette terre le chef
picard
que comptez-vous faire avec cette loi
becqueter j'ai envie de commencer par
une réflexion qui m'avaient été faites
qui m'avait été partagé puis que je
partageais moi même parce que c'est venu
d'une famine ou qu'ils disent est
évidemment en innu il ya quelques années
bon
juste quand est ce qu'on va décider
qu'on qu'on ait finalement rendu à
destination
c'est une lutte qu'on mène depuis
plusieurs décennies voire plusieurs
plusieurs décennies pour certains
d'entre nous dans les personnes qui nous
ont précédés et donc on prend un peu la
relève mais en même temps je crois que
la base nos populations sont en droit de
se demander bon c'est quoi la caisse qui
nous attend quand est ce qu'on va aller
au delà de l'espoir et qu'on va pouvoir
finalement concrétisé ce qu'on appelle
ce qu'on appellerait finalement les
objectifs que ce que nous pensions c'est
une excellente question par rapport à la
loi sur les indiens
ça fait partie de ces défis là écoutez
c'est un lien aussi un peu avec la
discussion précédant ce que nous avions
et je m'en remet d'ailleurs à l'histoire
un peu parce que ce qui a fait défaut le
processus constitutionnel a frappé un
mur au milieu des années 80 les c'est
normal beaucoup aussi lié un ctac et
capacités lors du canada mais aussi des
provinces comme juridictions
provinciales et territoriales de
vraiment de nous accorder la marge de
manoeuvre nécessaire ses revenus encore
en 92 avec charlotte ans et est pour moi
bien finalement l'aspect dont on a peu
parlé et qui à mon sens est vraiment
fondamental c'est toute la question de
la territorialité monsieur lévesque le
disait lui-même parce qu'il y avait
quand même participer à ces processus
processus là finalement lorsque ça a
chauffé
lorsqu'on on a eu une conclusion
négative pour les premières nations
monsieur lévesque disait ben ce que je
comprends c'est que c'était un problème
de pouvoir mais de territoire aussi et
c'est là qu'on a énormément difficulté
d'ailleurs
lorsque quelqu'un suis un peu
l'environnement politique autour de nous
il faut être attentif à tout ce qui se
passe il faut être en contact avec nos
collègues des autres régions savoir
comment les autres régions respire par
rapport à ces questions non et la
démarche annoncée par monsieur trudeau
en février 2018 sur un cadre de
reconnaissance de nos droits ancestraux
il ya un joueur qui manque c'est la
province les provinces et les
territoires
donc pour moi la loi sur les indiens ben
oui on peut mettre le couvert là dessus
mais ça prend un processus qui respecte
surtout les communautés et même là il ya
une diversité importante au chapitre des
opinions qui sont exprimées par nos
communautés
il faut aussi savoir je reviens sur la
tempe savoir penser embarque donc on
s'en balance que pour les communautés
quelques pensées c'est peut-être un peu
paradoxal mais la loi sus aux indiens
c'est quelque chose de concret qu'est ce
qui se passe demain si elle est pas le
fait que c'est une bonne question sont
finies seulement semblant de
l'engagement de notre population dans la
réflexion une autre question je veux
l'imposer tout de suite parce que je
vois leur qui file est vraiment j'ai
envie qu'on y réponde c'est stéphanie
christine louvre caron qui demandent
d'ailleurs il sent qu'elle n'est pas la
seule à se poser la question
elle nous dit quand nous les métis
seront reconnus comme autochtones
alors monsieur dominique je vous laisse
répondre
hélas elle rajoute 1 3 petits points
dans un avenir proche donc est ce qu'un
jour les métis seront reconnus comme
autochtone si vous êtes grand chelem de
la pnq elle je pense quoi cette
l'autorité l'aude et des chefs de la
peine qu elles servent à l'expliquer 2 2
d'avoir ça peu de de cette
responsabilité
pardonnez moi alors ok mais c'est clair
que puis je crois qu'il ya des
jurisprudences qui est assez claire à ce
niveau là qui identifie un peu lors les
paramètres que les médecins qui se
déclarent qui s'autoproclament médecin
doit respecter pour effectivement à se
faire reconnaître comme peuple donc moi
je pense que il ya une balise qui qui
est là dans mon esprit au québec il n'ya
pas de communauté métisse hockey dans
l'histoire au québec
par contre il ya des gens bien entendu
qu'ils ont subi du médecin jean pineau
nos communautés le font l'objet
également l'autre 2100 métissage entre
les premières nations un et bien entendu
entre les autres sociétés l'eau ici par
l'ondé des québécois et des québécoises
donc c'est clair que your phénomène de
médecins qui qui est là qui qui est
acceptée qui qui qui fait qu'ils qui
démontre bien entendu là tout
l'ouverture alors que traditionnellement
les premières nations lors ont pu avoir
la rue avec les les nouveaux arrivants à
une certaine époque mais pour une
reconnaissance comme une société
ok il ya une législation iodé des
critères l'eau
jeudi son lob puis personnellement
j'estime qu'au québec il n'y a pas de
société
mathieu picard vous répondez quoi cette
question de madame stéphanie christine
louvre caron d'abord c'est une très très
bonne question et c'est une question qui
est venu frapper à notre porte souvent
dans l'histoire de la pnq elle est
d'abord pour bien situer les choses
c'est que la nation métisse est reconnu
au niveau constitutionnel il ya 3par
acteur les premières nations les métis
et les inuits et l'on tombe un autre
état pour l'autre élément qui touche la
définition lorsqu'on regarde les entités
nationales qui représente la nation
métisse
elles ont elles ont une définition très
précise c'est vraiment les descendants
de la rivière rouge donc les excédents
de louis riel
ils ont entre en jeu la question de la
territorialité parce que j'ai de la
misère un pas situer le territoire j'ai
vu une carte bon ça s'envole jusqu'à ça
couvre à peu près la moitié de la cour
but à nec jusqu'à la moitié de près de
l'ontario donc et même source est
contestée parmi nos nations soeur des
prairies donc il ya cette question l'eau
qui est également extrêmement dirait
préoccupante pour certaines nations mais
en même temps il ya eu des tentatives
devant les tribunaux d'ailleurs il y en
a une au québec mme heim mais passons à
celles qui ont peut-être contribué
allergies un peu à élargir un peu cette
définition de métier c'est en
particulier l'arrêt parler en ontario où
vivait mais même avec cette garantie
légale l'emploi appelons la comme ça il
en demeure pas moins que des conflits
quand même lorsqu'il s'agit de la
question territoriale et les algonquins
de l'ouest du québec en savent quelque
chose parce qu'elles ont des
revendications
revendications territoriales qui h à
veauche la frontière québec ontario
poétique qui est contesté par des
entités qui se prétendent avec un statut
égal ou leur donc c'est extrêmement
complexe et la question j'en suis sûr
convaincu va revenir chez nous également
mais en même temps je dis remparts
intense aujourd'hui en marge de tout ça
ce qu'on constate aussi c'est des
groupes qui apparaissent qui nice avec
des noms on sait pas d'où ça origine
quant à nous d'aider des pures
inventions et qui réclament des statuts
qui sont égales aux nôtres il ya aussi
cet aspect l'eau qui vient sans doute
contribué ou ajouter à la confusion
plutôt mais en même temps ceci étant dit
la question du métissage c'est une
réalité qui est indéniable au québec
mais de là à voir une reconnaissance
qu'ils soient similaires par exemple à
la reconnaissance de la nation métisse
telle qu'on inscrit dans la constitution
canadienne
on arrive vraiment un autre chat péter
j'espère
et pour moi ben saada marre vraiment une
responsabilité aussi de du cercle des
chefs de se pencher ce qu'est son lot et
dormir peut-être avec une position
définitive sur la question alors le
facebook l'avait commencé donc là tout
d'un coup les gens ont envie de poser
des questions y en a plein qui rentrent
donc je vais vous reposer une autre
avant éventuellement on va terminer en
vous demandant évidemment vos priorités
là en tant que chef de la pm tu es tu
pour l'un ou l'autre mais avant une
question qui nous vient de cocoon
tremblay qui dit qu attendent les
gouvernements pour mieux financer les
bandes et les communautés éloignées
alors je vais vous laisser reprendre
votre respiration monsieur denis je me
retournais vers vous donc qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous répondez à cette
question qu'est ce que vous attendez qu
est-ce qu attendait gouvernement pour
mieux financer les bandes et les
communautés éloignées
il faut faudrait leur adresser ce
questionnement l'eau
au gras vins au gouvernement encore aux
simples inattendu mais moi j'ai une
opinion lors à ce niveau là honnêtement
vous savez là moi je sème le chaos on
est considéré comme
nous les premières nations nos défis nos
enjeux et tout ça on a comme un
programme qui est instaurée au canada
hockey d'un bout à l'autre du pays
et on se questionne pas plus que ça sur
effectivement l'eau les individus qui
sont desservis par ces programmes là on
ne tient pas compte non plus de leurs
besoins de leurs particularités de leur
défi de leur histoire de leurs
traditions de leurs coutumes enfin
l'ambiance un programme là
mur à mur et on essaie de passer bien
entendu l'ensemble des premières nations
dans ce trou de serrure là puis on le
mentionnait ça ne fait pas du tout la
job par rapport aux bénéfices souhaiter
de la part de nos populations au pire
que ça moi je pense à nous maintient
l'ordre dans un état de dépendance
étatique là en lien avec tous ces
éléments là donc c'est clair les besoins
sont beaucoup plus grands bien entendu
et plusieurs organisations plusieurs
conseils d'abandon
démontrer et inévitablement l'eau il ya
peu des coudes pour pas dire pas des
coutelas de la part des gouvernements
puis honnêtement par rapport au fédéral
à ce moment ci quoique le discours de
monsieur trudeau semble intéressant
semble bon en temps à nos oreilles
il faut se rendre à l'évidence que ce
plan administratif
l'appareil du gouvernement du canada n'a
pas livré la marchandise
on est encore un de ces camps
en termes de financement
il ya des formules de financement qui
tiennent pas la loi
il ya des erreurs par tous ok et quand
on leur faire la démonstration europe is
réajuste d'inattendu pour tenter quand
même là devenir la paramétrer de
financement que les premières nations
vont obtenir c'est ça pas de sens donc
il faut bien entendu s'organiser se
mobiliser pour s'assurer de bien
comprendre la façon que le financement
est octroyée et définit bien entendu
dans un premier temps pour pouvoir mieux
influencer leur le développement de ces
formules nord est la meilleure façon à
mon sens c'est justement là avec une apn
qu elles qui vont être fortes et la
création d'un forum politique où on voit
débarrassé de ses vraies affaires l'ont
alors chers clients vous avez vous aussi
sûrement une opinion sur cette question
d'adopter une autre excellente question
est pour moi bon on est on s'active
actuellement la redéfinir la relation
fiscale entre le gouvernement fédéral et
les premières nations dans l'ensemble du
pays et le défi qui se présente à nous
c'est de faire en sorte que les réalités
régionales puissent avoir voix au
chapitre également est à mon sens c'est
aussi je dirais peut-être un défi qui se
présente à cette grande diversité que
nous représentons parce que le phénomène
des communautés éloignées basse est
présent dans plusieurs autres régions du
pays
au québec également et je pense que ce
qu'on met au test finalement sur les
capacités des communautés avec plus de
moyens plus de capacité peut-être plus
populeuse - les douaniers moins isolés
de pouvoir finalement contribué à une
démarche qui soit beaucoup plus
collective et je sors je pense que c'est
extrêmement important sur la question du
du financement du un exemple qui est
très probants qui me vient à l'esprit
c'est celui de l'éducation et on est
loin lors de d'avoir atteint l'idéal au
chapitre de l'éducation est à mon sens
notre pire ennemi c'est pas les envolées
oratoires de justin trudeau notre pire
ennemi c'est l'appareil gouvernemental
et c'est là malheureusement qu'on
continue à se buter
lorsqu'on il s'agit d'avancer des
positions qui viendrait peut-être qui va
nous permettre aux communautés d'aller
chercher les bénéfices qu'elle mérite
et ceci étant dit un autre aspect que je
trouve extrêmement important c'est que
lorsque les budgets seront à la hauteur
de ce qu'on attend qu'ils soient
comparables à ce qui existe ailleurs
est ce que nos structures de gouvernance
voire à la hauteur
et ça ça fait partie de mon plan à moi
d'assurer que finalement l'ensemble de
des personnes qui se donnent corps et
âme à structurer nos administrations
locales notre fonction publique générait
soit vraiment dispose de tous les moyens
passé pour pouvoir servir leurs
communautés de la façon de façon
répondent aux besoins et aux attentes
des communautés sorte je trouve que
c'est extrêmement important puis je le
suis vraiment en tout respect parce que
les avancées ce jeudi
varie d'une communauté à une autre il ya
plusieurs aspects l'eau qui explique son
éloignement notamment des communautés
c'est une des raisons il y en a d'autres
mais je pense que il faut aussi se
préparer à cette transition dont et ça
me ramène à la question de la madame de
de la famine ou là que je relevé un peu
plus tôt quand est ce qu'on arrive à
destination
esso il faut s'y préparer et je pense
que c'est le rôle de la pnq elle de
faire en sorte que d'abord les
communautés soient pleinement impliqués
par la démarche et pour le bénéfice
évidemment des communautés que nous
représentons et de leurs idéaux
alors on va se permettre de prendre un
peu plus de temps que d'habitude parce
qu'il ya d'autres questions qui remplit
en fait c'est vraiment important que
vous soyez là pour y répondre qu'on va
profiter de vous alors question suivante
la question vient de guy paul il dit
qu'est ce qui se passe avec les coupes
forestières les barrages et les mines
dans le nitassinan donc dans le
territoire nous n'entendons presque rien
sur les négociations qui sont en cours
monsieur dominique je sais pertinemment
que je veux parler peut-être pour ma
communauté
il ya des négociations effectivement
avec les promoteurs ce qu'ils entendent
développer
le territoire prélever des ressources
naturelles et c'est donc une obligation
bien entendu de s'entendre avec nous
donc des exercices comme ça qu'ils qui
se font des négociations la de cette
façon là qui se font la cour à nan je
vous dirais avec ma communauté mais je
convaincu avec plusieurs autres
premières nations donc j'imagine comme
notre communauté le fait dans le passé
aussi lorsque les résultats sont
probants
un projet satisfaisant un projet de
développement est satisfaisant répond qu
tellement que on s'est donné leur en
matière de développement également
à nos conditions en matière d'impact
environnemental parce que n'oublions pas
que lorsque lyonnais pâquis
environnementale l'impact est intimement
liée également à la pratique de nos
activités traditionnelles parce que nos
activités traditionnelles qui nous
caractérise la tellement tellement bien
ben ils sont forgé à partir de nos
activités traditionnelles que nous
pratiquons régulièrement alors en
territoire donc si on n'aime pas que
l'environnement inévitablement ça
n'impacte directement sur cet élément là
qui est hautement important donc au
niveau des prochains jeux parce que il
ya des ja d
des négociations qui sont au nord et si
effectivement il ya un hurluberlu leurs
promoteurs qui entendent développer
quelque chose qui va pas cogner à la
porte lors de la nation là qui occupe un
territoire
moi je pense qu'il faut le prendre en
défaut et la peinture est effectivement
l on pourrait bien sûr venir soutenir la
les a laissés communauté l'a nnée
s'assurer que les entreprises les méga
entreprise la respecte le processus de
consultation le processus la garde mais
qui va les amener à conclure des
arrangements lors d'une entente par
exemple de développement avec la
première nation concernée donc ça c'est
fondamentalement important l'autre champ
asos c'est l'obligation du gouvernement
dans ce cas aussi du québec la matière
de consultation ok donc lieu un
responsable gouvernemental
il faut que le québec n'a accompagne les
promoteurs et s'assurer fait main du
respect parce que c'est eux
en bout de ligne pour être là mais en
porte à faux par les premières nations
et tout ça je vous dirais là que s'est
beaucoup amélioré et ça ferait partie
assurément de là j'ai donc les chefs se
pomponner tic pourraient se donner et
qui pourrait être incité par un éventuel
forum
formelles avec les gouvernements voilà
est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
répète la question monsieur picard non
non non je lis bien tenu et c'est une
autre belle question et qui encore une
fois dans ce cas ci met en évidence un
peu les défis qui se présentent à nous
entre nous aussi
par rapport à cette grande question de
du territoire écoutez j'ai envie d'y
aller avec un constat que je fais de
l'environnement politique présent et qui
doit extrêmement préoccupant parce que
encore une fois ça vaut pour la province
à vous pour le fédéral il faut vraiment
essayer de trouver la porte d'entrée
pour essayer d'influencer le processus
le prochain processus électoral au
niveau fédéral je pense à l'éducation
chanson ou logement je pense à la
sécurité publique il faut vraiment faire
valoir faire valoir un peu nos priorités
comme premières nations mais ceci étant
dit je dirais aussi j'en fais une
parenthèse qu on a réussi à acquérir une
bonne crédibilité dans la relation avec
les autres nations des chances du pays à
travers le pays qu elle mais aussi à
travers nos commissions régionales qui
ont cette capacité de mettre en évidence
pas être ce que nous considérons comme
étant des déshéritant dans la relation
entre le gouvernement fédéral et nos
communautés et écouter l'environnement
politique l'arène politique la façon
qu'il se dessine
au cours des prochains mois on a comme
si on avait pas assez d'un parti
conservateur on va en avoir deux et on
sait que la réalité du québec pèse
beaucoup dans la prochaine élection
fédérale
donc il va falloir faire des efforts
surhumains pour se tailler une place est
à mon sens et l'argent revient avec le
gouvernement trudeau peut-être que la
meilleure option
si la question est posée aujourd'hui
c'est encore une fois les libéraux mais
encore une fois tout n'est pas parfait
là on a accusé le plus de recul cédant
la réforme des politiques qui viennent
finalement dessiner les paramètres trop
restrictif par rapport à la question qui
est posée au chapitre du territoire la
politique de revendication la police et
de revendications globales la politique
de revendication particulière
l'ajout de territoire aux réserves tout
des éléments l'eau qui vaut convergent
un peu cette grande question qui est
aussi une préoccupation par rapport au
territoire donc à mon sens est encore
une fois le grand absent c'est le québec
le québec qui assume ses jaunes section
nord est qui et qui évidemment a
toujours continué un constamment cherché
à éviter ces questions là également
voilà alors on dit qu'on va perdre
saguenay dans à peu près 5 6 minutes
donc on veut pas vous perdre tout de
suite monsieur dominique il ya d'autres
questions alors ce que je vous
proposerai peut-être à vous deux c'est
d'aller sur la page facebook des espaces
autochtone d'aller répondre aux gens qui
posent d'autres questions parce que des
questions vraiment intéressante sur la
parité hommes femmes
une question également sur les langues
autochtones à défendre donc on y
répondra pas tout de suite je vais
mouiller je vais vous laisser y aller
après mais ce que je vais vous demander
pour terminer ce facebook live c'est de
me parler de vos priorités
si vous devenez ou si vous revenez chef
de la pnq l monsieur dominique mercy
beaucoup donc moi je vais proposer au
chef un plein de matches lors en
faussant de cinq grands axes
la première l'autonomie des premières
nations
1 honnêtement la justin locke quand les
premières nations vont enfin pleinement
assumé cette responsabilité là on vaut
mieux faire avec le gouvernement fédéral
ok on vend à shell assumer adéquatement
et on va véritablement laurent d'édition
qui ont des impacts positifs sur nos
premières nations donc une autonomie qui
va être basé sur nos droits ancestraux
bien entendu une autonomie financière
aussi parce que si on veut parler
d'autonomie inévitablement là il faut
parler également de la capacité
financière et où est également l'hôte de
venir accompagner le développement des
expertises et des compétences l'ont en
matière d'autonomie également dans
l'ensemble des déchets que nous allons
prendre comme responsabilité l'eau
tellement qui à mon sens c'était
important c'est notre identité
1 ce qui nous caractérise comme
premières nations donc il faut s'assurer
de continuer leur assurer la continuité
de la pratique de nos activités
traditionnelles de notre culture de nos
langues il faut valoriser notre histoire
bien entendu eu nos traditions il faut
profiter de l'année internationale des
des langues autochtones pour lui donner
un statut pourquoi pas je pense
s'apprêtent à défiler tout à fait
exceptionnel a tellement inspirant pour
les jeunes des premières nations
il ya un autre axe et le territoire le
traître territoire traditionnel 1 à
laquelle nous sommes intimement liées le
comme premières nations il faut
continuer de l'occuper l'occupé parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on va perpétuer la
transmission de nos valeurs de nos
coutumes de notre culture
à l'ensemble des des prochaines
générations mais également il faut pour
assurer notre développement comme
société parce qu'on a aussi des besoins
il faut profiter d'un accès aux
ressources naturelles pour justement
alors développer nos propres économies
il faut prendre compte également la de
notre responsabilité comme gardiens de
la terre en matière environnementale
dont moi je pense qu'il faut se déployer
le niveau là il faut également un autre
axe qui m'apparaît important c'est les
conditions de vie des premières nations
le niveau de pauvreté qui maintient les
familles dans la dépendance c'est
dévastateur au niveau des des premières
nations
sans parler des fléaux sociaux loki
keane ou bien tu donc c'est sûr qu'il
faut s'assurer de continuer de livrer
toujours de grosses batailles se plaît
pas détient pour s'assurer que il ya un
financement là à la hauteur des réels
besoins là et deux de nos communautés et
bien sûr s'attaquer à la pénurie de
logements là qui sévit dans plusieurs
communautés
l'autre axe qui à mon sens est important
c'est l'économie des premières nations
1 il faut là chaque communauté visée un
emploi pour l'ensemble de nos jeunes
c'est ça qui voit les inspirer pour
rester dans les bancs d'école il faut
bien entendu supporter la création la
d'entreprise dans nos communautés
il faut également là bien sûr la
supporter la création favoriser la
création de partenariats entre les
premières nations
on a une masse est intéressant si on met
en commun lors des projets là ensemble
donc pourquoi pas le faire il faut bien
sûr la s'assurer d'avoir accès à des
leviers de financement parce que vous
savez à cause de la loi sur les indiens
l'accès au financement extrêmement
difficile là
pour faire développer nos projets mais
j'ai en terminant je vais jouer juste
peux pas me permettre de vous adresser
le quelques priorités très rapidement
que j'entends recommandé au chef puis la
première est intimement lié au drame qui
s'est passé lors à val d'or avec les
femmes des premières nations
les femmes ont perdu confiance au
système de justice au niveau du terme
être au niveau du québec tarde les mois
c'est dramatique car ces femmes
pourraient ne pas dénoncer c'est
inadmissible il faut rétablir cette
confiance qu'il faut permettre aux
femmes de pouvoir dénoncer leurs
agresseurs et être soutenus là est
protégé bien entendu non pas être jugé
sa place publique dont moi je pense que
c'est un chantier qui rapidement là le
canal politique doit être mise à
contribution d'autres priorités bien sûr
qu'il faut provoquer des états généraux
la avec les chefs et les élus des
premières nations faut déterminer la
mission et la responsabilité de la peine
qu elle il faut actualiser nos
structures pour les rendent bien entendu
leur efficace dans l'accompagnement
l'eau dans le développement des des
communautés moi je pense qu'il faut
créer un forum politique avec le
gouvernement du québec et la peine qu
elle pourquoi le québec parce qu'on vont
il faut aborder rapidement la question
des ressources la question du territoire
l'accessibilité leur territoire par les
premières nations mais je pense si la à
la lourdeur entourant la question des ex
des mecs qui empêche une circulation
lors correct la part de nos mains le
dossier de la sécurité publique les
services à l'enfance et aux moi je pense
que dans un premier temps rapidement on
pourrait créer ce canal là avec le
gouvernement du québec et voir comment
est ce qu'on peut faire évoluer son jeu
propose également l'hôtel drouot chef
d'entamer une négociation avec le québec
pour le partage des redevances de
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
l'ensemble des municipalités au québec
reçoit des mondes à partir de vente chez
les premières nations
c'est zéro je le serai peut-être la fin
avec l'idée peut-être là c'est une
vision mais moi je pense qu'ensemble
d'ensemble est à la fois communauté nous
pourrions livrer une bataille de tous
les instants pour que le québec qu'on
vienne avec nous pour moi au moins 1000
à 2000 mégawatts exploitées ou à
développer dans les prochaines années
soit de propriété des premières nations
on a droit de bénéficier des rangées de
ses projets pour l'autonomie financière
une provocation alors je propose
merci beaucoup monsieur dominique je
risque de vous perdre dans quelques
instants lorsque j'explique la suite
monsieur picard va lui aussi pouvoir
parler de ses priorités
ensuite il va nous expliquer comment
vont se dérouler les élections la
semaine prochaine donc si je vous perd
entre temps merci d'avoir été là
aujourd'hui
merci d'avoir répondu à mes questions
également aux questions des internautes
et puis monsieur dominique s'il vous
plaît allez sur le site sur notre page
facebook pour répondre à ces internautes
qui vous ont posé des questions alors
prenez le temps d'aller leur répondre
merci monsieur dominique absolument
merci au bout et puis bonne chance et
bonne chance pour cette élection la
semaine prochaine alors monsieur picard
donc c'est à votre tour de répondre
monsieur dominique a pris à peu près
cinq minutes donc je vous donne à peu
près cinq minutes pour répondre à cette
question
bah écoutez je sais c'est clair pour moi
que con médecins le cap comme je le
disais plus tôt sur l'importance pour la
pnq elle d'occuper de continuer
d'occuper l'espace public et pour moi ça
passe beaucoup par
je dirais cette obligation de vraiment
faire en sorte comme on le dit si bien
dit souvent que les premières nations
leurs droits sont des incontournables et
c'est un peu ce qui ce qui a guidé
toutes les positions que nous avons
prises sur tout sujet danic et même des
situations où on a tendance à penser au
québec c'est là leur position ça ne nous
concerne pas tous nous concerne je donne
l exemple tôt et je me permets d'y
revenir parce que c'est extrêmement
important
le ministre de l'emploi du québec
il y aura peut-être quelques jours bon
réagissait encore une fois cette
question de pénurie de main d'oeuvre et
pour la première fois j'ai constaté qui
a ajouté les communautés que nous
représentons comme étant peut-être qu'en
faisant partie de la solution donc c'est
peut-être des gains sont minimes mais si
on ne les utilise pas pour pour comme
capitale mais ça reste minime et je
pense que ce sens est une responsabilité
qui nous revient de toute évidence pour
moi ce qui est important c'est comme je
disais je réitère et je le dis souvent
aux chefs d'ailleurs c'est que notre
propre relation indices nation l'anglais
le français comme réalité linguistique
au delà des langues autochtones mais
pour moi c'est extrêmement important
aussi qu'on puisse trouver la bonne
formule d'engagement entre nous et ce
que je j'ai déjà suggéré comme approche
et que ou lieu de faire des assemblées
comme nous le faisons régulièrement
trois quêtes par annie peut-être que la
consultation de devrait
finalement se faire au niveau national
c'est à dire les chefs d'une même nation
réunis autour de leur table des conseils
tribaux et qu'on puisse finalement
au-delà de la responsabilité du chef
régional de participer à des
inaugurations couper des rubans ce que
je néglige pas mais en même temps est-ce
qu'il ya moyen de se donner l'espace
nécessaire pour avoir une conversation
et peut-être comme préalable aux
assemblées des chefs peut-être que ça va
venir faciliter la prise de décision la
prise de décision tout un aspect
extrêmement important et la réforme que
je propose le lac à l'époque je propose
cette question doit être au menu
également l'autre question c'est la
gouvernance est ce que le gouvernement
du fédéral fait depuis des jours la
décision de scinder le ministère des
affaires autochtones en duo d'enfer deux
ministères velho un processus de
transformation qui régit les programmes
actuels et les cours que nous avons des
communautés c'est que les communautés
s'y perdre ne s'y retrouve pas les ce
qu'on propose et d'un espace de quelques
mois c'est la tenue d'un grand exercice
de mobilisation qui va contribuer a
ajouté m un peu d'éclairage en tous sens
pour que les communautés se retrouvent
sur la base des besoins que seules les
communautés caennaise et ça je pense que
c'est important de se donner également
cet espace non la déclaration de l'onu
vraiment un incontournable ça nous
sommes pris tellement de temps je veux
dire entre 2007 2010 un gouvernement
fédéral qui était s'obstinait à ne pas
la reconnaître
on a fait des efforts à ce moment là
québec solidaire a été acquis on a
travaillé avec le parti québécois pour
que en 2010 madame marois se présente
publiquement et 10 on reconnaît la
déclaration de l'onu
on est loin de l'idéal encore une fois
mais je veux dire on deux fois en 12 ans
ne doit pas s'asseoir sur nos lauriers
et encore dénomme démarches afin sur la
question en quelques secondes
écoutez j'étais avec le juge vient en
décembre dernier on a vraiment tout
écouter ce qui a été dit dans les
audiences de la commission de l'ua m
on a finalement eu d'arrache-pied on
avait un gouvernement qui était
réfractaire à l'idée qu'il n'y ait même
la question du racisme systémique et est
ce qu'on a dit c'est que c'est clair que
la question de la relation entre nos
populations et la sûreté du québec des
forces policières doit être réglée la
sûreté du québec n'a toujours pas
exprimé des excuses par rapport aux
événements de val-d'or et ça c'est tout
à fait à fait inacceptable inconcevable
donc ce qu'on dit et pour cela les deux
commissions autant celle au niveau
national sur les femmes autochtones
disparues et assassinées que la
commission vient on doit pourvoir sortir
du québec est allé chercher des
mécanismes internationaux pour faire en
sorte que justice soit rendue au niveau
des femmes autochtones
il sort c'est quelque chose qu'on nous
nous engageons enfin au delà de ce lob
derniers temps
terminé le temps mais la dernière
question c'est est bon parce que vous
connaissez un peu comment ça fonctionne
les élections pour l'apn thuel comment
ça va se passer la semaine prochaine
donc mercredi jour d'élection les 43
chefs des dix communautés représentées
votes d'écart entre au chef elle veut
dire les grandes prochaine de chacune
des communes aux mollahs d'écart au
droit communautaire quasi nation tout à
fait oui les actifs c'est quand même
relativement simples comme processus
c'est pas très très élaboré la raison qu
il explique c'est que comme je le disais
plus tôt la peine qu elles ne sont
jamais
donc les processus propre aux nations
qui élisent leurs enchères par vote
populaire
c'est pas dans notre réalité mais ceci
étant dit le processus que quand même
simple les candidats se présentent font
part de leur programme et il revient au
chef par la suite de dorothée donc la
prévision de 30 janvier oui c'est ça
donc ça sera rapide 1 rapidement je suis
oui tout à fait voilà alors si vous avez
d'autres questions
je leur ai tendu la perche ils vont
aller sur le titre si la page facebook
des espaces autochtone pour répondre aux
questions que vous aviez la au cours de
notre facebook live donc arrêtez d'en
poser parce qu'évidemment il ne rompt
pas tout pour y répondre
alors on va prendre les quelques
questions qui restent si vous avez la
chance monsieur picard dali répondre je
rappelle que vous êtes le chef sortant
de l'assemblée des premières nations du
québec et du labrador
gilbert dominique et l'ancien chef de
mashteuiatsh tous les deux vous êtes
candidat donc comme chef de la pnq elle
est la semaine prochaine mercredi nous
saurons qui sera le prochain chef pour
un mandat de trois ans alors bonne
chance à tous les deux et surtout merci
vraiment un gros gros merci d'avoir
accepté de participer à cette émission
en facebook lite merci beaucoup merci à
vous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
oh